you know i'm 12 months older than you
age
is just a number but when it comes to
siblings who are close in age
to be 10 years apart can be pretty weird
which bridgeton's sister is actually
14 years older than her character wanda
and pietro may be twins but
what age difference do the actors
actually have between them
what about the much bigger age
difference in real life between these
stranger things siblings
i certainly enjoy spreading secrets do
not little eloise bridgeton is a
definite young firecracker but it
turns out she actually isn't so little
in real life she is way older than her
sister daphne
while in the show eloise is 17 and
daphne is 21 actress claudia jesse is
31 years old that makes her a whole six
years older than phoebe denver who's
only 26 now
this stranger things sibling duo get
along so well it's hard to believe they
aren't actually four years apart in age
jonathan portrayed by charlie heaton was
born in 1994
a whole 10 years earlier than actor noah
schnapp
age is definitely just a number for
these two why you always hanging out
with me
because you're my best friend let's
throw back to the amazing spider-man and
its sequel
remember gwen stacy's older brother well
it turns out actor charlie de pew is
actually
much younger than emma stone and by way
more than we would have expected
de pew was 18 in the film being born in
1996 and emma stone was born eight years
earlier in 1988.
i gotta do what i gotta do you know
gossip girl here to tell you that dan
and jenny humphrey
nowhere near as close in age in real
life in the show dan and jenny are
pretty close and only have a two-year
age gap
though let's be honest dan humphrey
didn't look like
any boys we went to high school with
which makes sense since penn badgley was
actually a whole
five years older than his character you
guys are watching it on me
actress taylor momsen on the other hand
well she actually played her own age on
the show
i'm not a little girl anymore since
being delighted with wandavision we got
to see
two different pietros with elizabeth
olsen's wanda even though evan peters
pietro wasn't real pietro he was
definitely
real enough when he showed up in west
view that is so
rad lame wanda and pietro are of course
twins
but in both pietro circumstances they're
far from it
elizabeth olsen is a full two years
older than her age of ultron brother
and has the same age difference with
evan peters except
in reverse peters is the oldest pietro
ringing in at two years older than olsen
oh the shepherd siblings or should we
say the mcdreamy siblings
both derrick and patrick dempsey were
born in 1966
while emilia shepherd was born seven
years later the actress who plays her
katarina scorsoni was actually born a
whole
15 years after dempsey you're my
favorite sister
even if he's much older than amelia in
real life he will
always be mcdreamy meredith and lexi
though their relationship was fraught to
begin with and meredith didn't
really want to have anything to do with
lex when she first arrived the two grew
to be one of our favorite sibling pairs
the two were half-sisters with six years
between them meredith was born in 1978
and lexi in 1982 after thatcher got
together with her mom
actress tyler lee is actually younger
than ellen pompeo
but by double the age difference in the
show that's right
lee as a whole 12 years younger than
pompeo
and that's a true story by the way so no
one is really sure how old emily of
emily in paris is
even lily collins got it wrong in an
interview what we do know is that she
and her parisian bff camille are about
the same age and it seems like they're
somewhere in their mid-20s
as for camille's younger brother well we
know for
sure he is only 17 since it was
awkwardly announced at the breakfast
table after it was revealed that emily
slept with him
oh my god thank goodness the actors who
played camille and timothee weren't
actually that far apart in age
camille rosette is pretty close to her
age in the show at 26
and victor muerle emily's awkward
one-night stand
is actually 22. definitely makes the
whole situation less creepy
i didn't know another set of twins who
guess what
aren't actually twins cersei and jaime
were both 44 in season 8 and their
younger brother tyrion was 39 but in
reality
those numbers aren't so accurate how do
you know this
that's what i do i drink and i know
things
actors nikolai koster valdau and lena
heady are
nowhere near being twins being born
three years apart nikolai in 1970 and
lina in 1973.
as for their younger brother instead of
five years younger he's actually one and
four years older than his got siblings
the king slayer brothers
you like it i like it is it just us or
if spencer and melissa hastings not
exactly looked like they had a seven
year age gap it was a mistake
while we figured they weren't a full
seven years apart in real life like they
are in the show
we definitely couldn't have imagined
that they'd be almost the exact same age
troy and belisario and tori devito
actually only have
one year between them similar to the dan
humphrey situation
troy and belisario was playing a
teenager when she was already in her 20s
yeah all my dreams came true calling all
modern family fans
what is their love about these two
sisters i've been battling hot shaming
my entire life
please don't say hot lives matter while
haley and alex were both mature in their
own ways
they carried out their sibling dynamics
so well on the show
we were totally floored to learn that
the two of them are eight years apart in
age
actress sarah hyland was playing younger
and ariel winter was playing older
on the show the two were born almost
exactly two years apart but in real life
highland was born three years earlier
than her character and winter a full two
years after her character alex
she was only in the film for a brief
moment but if we're being honest
regina george's little sister kylie is
iconic
actress nicole creamy pulled off playing
an eight-year-old really well because
well she was actually eight years old
how about her sister queen to the
plastics regina george
george may have been 16 but when rachel
mcadams did the movie
she was 10 years older than her
character and was already 26.
eight years is a fairly big age gap when
it comes to siblings
but it's nothing compared to the 18
years the two actors actually had
between them
this is the face i make when i don't
understand you
damon and stefan a vampire diaries okay
so yes their characters were both over a
hundred years old but
obviously they didn't look it they were
both born in the 1800s but on the show
they portrayed their much younger selves
the two do have a pretty significant age
gap of about seven to eight years
depending on what month it is in reality
actor paul wesley
is still younger than his older
on-screen bro ian somerhalder but
by half of their age difference on the
show the two dreamy vampire actors are
only four years apart in age and
i'm very grateful for it let's talk
about the pearson triplets
first off kevin and kate the biological
two that survived when their mom had
triplets
while randall may not have been a
biological triplet he did share a
birthday with them so the big three was
a reality
i couldn't even create a fantasy world
without you guys kev
all of them were born in 1980 and in
real life actress christy metz is the
same age as kate
as for justin hartley and sterling brown
these two bros aren't even close to
being the same age as mets
both of them are a few years older in
actuality hartley is three years older
than his character and sterling brown
a whole four years watching kate and
sean's relationship over the course of
firefly lane was definitely
one of our favorite parts of the whole
series both the actors playing their
adult and children's selves had amazing
dynamics
on the show kate is the younger sibling
that pretty much endlessly annoys shawn
but
in real life kate would be the older
sister
sarah chalk is actually older than actor
jason mckinnon by a whole four years
we need a season two we can't believe
how far away from the characters ages so
many of these actors were
we can only imagine how much trickier it
would be to create the sibling dynamic
when one of the actors is so much older
than the other
which of these age gaps did you find
most surprising